we have to find the square root of eight
thousand eight hundred and thirty six
using the technique we had seen in the
previous video to use the technique we
need to know the squares of the first
ten digits and we also know that the
square root of a four-digit number will
always be two digits long and the number
eight thousand 836 will give us the
digits we draw a bar over two digits
from the right and then draw one over
the remaining digits this part gives us
the tens digit the number 88 will give
us the tens digit where does 88 lie in
the squares column it lies between 81
and 100 it lies between 9 squared and 10
squared
and to get the tens digit we take the
lower of the two nine will be the tens
digit how do we get the unit's digit the
units digit of the number eight thousand
eight hundred and thirty six is six
it implies that there are two
possibilities for the unit's digit it
can either be four or six because both
four times four and six times six will
give us the unit's digit as six but
which one will it be to find that we
multiply the tens digit with its
successor that will be nine times ten
which gives us 90 once this is done we
compare this number in the middle with
1988 as we can see is clearly less than
90 and that is why we take the lower
number four as 88 is less than 90 we can
say that the square root of eight
thousand 836 is ninety four and not 96
so the tens digit is easily found and
for the unit's digit we find the product
of the tens digit with its successor and
compare it with this number in the
middle if the number in the middle is
smaller we take the smaller one here and
if it's larger we take the larger one
here this even works with five digit
numbers if we know the squares of
slightly higher numbers
let's try finding the square root of 13
thousand six hundred and eighty-nine
these are the squares of the first ten
numbers
use the same technique we used for the
four-digit numbers we write the number
thirteen thousand six hundred and eighty
nine down and mark two digits from the
right and then we draw a bar over the
remaining digits we look at this number
the number 136 it is greater than 100 11
squared is 121 and 12 squared is 144 136
lies between these two it lies between
11 squared + 12 squared and we take the
lower of the two 11 now the units digit
of the number is 9 it means that the
unit's digit of its square root will
either be 3 or 7 3 times 3 is 9 and 7
times 7 gives us the unit's digit as 9
to know which of these two will be in
the unit's digit we multiply 11 with its
successor 11 times 12
that equals 132 now this number in the
middle is greater than 132 136 is
greater than 132 as 136 is greater than
132 we choose the larger of the two the
square root will equal 117 and not 113
that's how we can find the square roots
of large numbers really fast okay forget
large numbers what if I asked you to
find the square root of 164 how will you
find it 164 is not a perfect square so
how will you find the square root that's
exactly what we will cover in the next
few videos
you